enfin le groupement d'intérêt public ces
pages va même plus loin que la
fourniture de solutions informatiques
elle va jusqu'à éditer les bulletins de
salaire de ses adhérents ça représente
180 mille feuilles de paye tous les mois
pour ces établissements de santé 8500
pour le seul chu de dijon
gérald darmanin est venu constater
d'abord que la mise en place du
prélèvement à la source était dans les
temps mais aussi rassuré les chefs
d'entreprise sur leur rôle dans ce
nouveau système des chefs d'entreprise
qui ne veulent pas forcément devenir des
agents des impôts c'est bien
effectivement les agents des impôts qui
répondront aux questions des
contribuables en aucun cas effectivement
les entreprises mais entreprises
aujourd'hui elles sont déjà collecteurs
d'impôts elle collecte les cotisations
que l'on paye sur sa feuille de salaire
elles collectent la tva collecte la cg
est donc ce ne sera pas un travail
supplémentaire important à faire pour
l'entreprise
francis pennequin est à la tête d'une
entreprise familiale créée en 1970
salariés et quelques chantiers
emblématiques de dijon à son actif le
parking d'arcy le sous-sol de
l'auditorium
tout récemment les travaux de la cité de
la gastronomie pour lui le prélèvement à
la source
ça n'est pas une bonne solution je crois
qu'on aurait agi sur la mensualisation
c'était bien plus simple sans douleur
pour les entreprises sont problématiques
particulières pour les salariés et à
partir de là ça fonctionnait la
mensualisation ce n'est pas la
contemporanéité vous payer aujourd'hui
votre mensualisation sur l'impôt que
vous avez touché en revenus l'année
dernière cette année il ya encore 7
millions de personnes qui voient leurs
revenus changés et c'est pas évident
quand vous partez en retraite quand vous
changez de travail comme multi ville et
cdd quand vous êtes salarié agricole
s'est passé très difficile un an après
de payer des revenus qui est des impôts
qui ne correspond pas à vos revenus donc
je leur dis que c'est une mesure sociale
très importante pour tous les salariés
ressentent le prélèvement à la source
sera donc effectif au 1er janvier 2019
ce qui ne change pas en revanche c'est
bien la déclaration de revenus et c'est
en ce moment qu'il faut la remplir